and just like that oh that voice
that catchphrase sex and the city stands
like myself still cannot get over the
fact that it's coming back
she is losing her mind for good reason
but so is sarah jessica parker who was
more than happy we can tell behind the
map
to talk to a photog outside her shoe
store in manhattan
we're very excited can't wait to be back
on the streets of new york shooting
in our hometown have some very exciting
stories to tell so thank you
you know kev the last time i talked to
sarah jessica she said she so wanted
carrie to come back because she really
wanted to see what carrie would be like
in the social media age i just figured
this out you should be the fourth member
sorry y'all by the way someone else
who's excited
sjp's former co-star jennifer hudson
why'd you move to new york
to fall in love luis from st louis is
she
going to show up in sex in the city in
the scene so
that would be cool i'm down
sure cause this looks like a good one j
hud had a big part of the first sex in
the city movie
and with kim cattrell sitting out the tv
series reboot
how about a return i got two pieces of
good news it's gonna be one of those
moments where i said remember when i
talked to you and you told me you hadn't
heard but you had really heard no really
i mean you know you have something no
okay all right and talk about a dream
job can you believe this year marks the
15th anniversary of dream girls
the then 25 year old co-starred with
beyonce and won the oscar for best
supporting actress
it was her very first movie jennifer
hudson
that was a whirlwind back then and every
time i walked past the oscar i'm like
that was me i did where is that
oscar is it behind you somewhere it's
actually downstairs
but it's here keep the fab you see
how it works you know it was a role that
obviously changed my life
and and i'm still here 15 years later
now in her newest movie jennifer gets
animated in baba yaga
she's also an executive producer on the
interactive virtual reality film
that you can only experience through a
vr headset
listen carefully glenn close daisy
ridley and kate winslet
are also a part of the all-female voice
cast that premieres tomorrow
on oculus quest jennifer i have to
believe your son really liked playing
with this
he did he loved it again that's this is
how school should be done now
and i was like that's a great idea
2021 is going to be big for jennifer
after being delayed by pandemic
her biopic respect about the queen of
soul aretha franklin
finally comes out this summer how
important is it to play this role
it's a role of a lifetime you know to
betray a legend an icon of a lifetime
and to be
chosen by her to play her i just hope to
honor her wishes so get ready for it
because this is the year of respect
i'd like you to call me miss franklin